you and I talked all through the break
after that last call because there's so
much philosophy that is so needed in our
culture today instead of finger pointing
our local posture is a good friend of
mine dr. easily spoke this morning for
her devotional here and he said maturity
is no longer blaming your past you plan
your future and you live what was this
living the present will you loan your
press on the present you own the present
and you plan your future you know when
you don't and always heard a guy say
after 30 you can't blame your parents
anymore all right
you know and so you can't bring your up
right you can't blame your upbringing
you can only honor your upbringing and
so you can't blame it because if you
blame it then you you assume the
position of victim and every one under
the sound of our voice has something in
their past that if they assume that as
their identity would make them a victim
don't think everyone's got I love that
the counseling line is your childhood
tragedies become your adult biologies
right say that again
your childhood tragedies become your
adult biologies right psychologies so it
it's there's these things that happen to
you these traumas these these victim
hoods that over time you dwell on them
they become some of the the the the
brain chemistry range in your brain so
the cortisol brain chemistry that's
right way you process something is
reporters all kicks in and you you
associate that with fight or flight and
you got ran off to the races right and
it changes and you drop into that
default which is a negative behavior
right Wilson Anna's you've got to decide
the earlier the better
this happened these things happen these
things were stacked against me these
hurdles were laid in my path
yes yeah I grew up in a neighborhood
where if you didn't like something and
we're 12 years old you bust some behind
the nose you hit them right and so I
mean not metaphorically that no it's
something right like see if you can
break their face that's right
and got my nose busted a bunch of times
and my eyes blacked a few times and that
kind of stuff I'm 60 years old I don't
need to be doing that now that's that's
right and if that's your default
position
anger equals punch equals somebody fault
well it is right it's in there that's
still in there but I haven't hit anybody
in the nose and a very long time you've
worked hard
right and you surrounded yourself with
people and I think I think what I've
seen is both sides of this that the
conversation which is I'm entirely a
victim or nothing you were happy to you
move on is there is a level of I've got
to understand when I've hurt people I've
understand when I'm continue to hurt
people and I've got to change that
behavior I also have to understand often
people are using the best tools that
they have yeah
with to solve the problems that are in
front of them yeah and my great-granddad
may not have had a full bag of
screwdrivers and hammers and chisels he
may have had just a hammer that's what
he had that's what he used and that's
how he loved and now yeah they had some
bruises that had some changes that are
some things that we wanted differently
nowadays and that's cool and we're
learning but I can continue to refer
back to that continue to go back to that
yeah or I can honor and move on yeah I
mean I can take the positive out of it
and say okay I know how to fight mmm but
I don't have I can do it metaphorically
I can do it intellectually I can't even
do it legally if I need to but I don't
have to go around punching when I was
here 60 years old you're still punching
people knows you got an issue when I
when I I spent a small season training
with MMA fighters No yeah it was awesome
and these dudes little-known facts about
doctors these dudes were they were bad
dudes but what was yeah what were you in
there listen it's a whole other story
that's a whole other story but here's
the thing the tougher they were the more
gentle and kind and respectful they were
everywhere
yeah cuz they had nothing to prove right
talking to a guy played Center in the
NFL the other day he played for like 14
years he's the most emotionally
controlled guy or no and he can run over
a car and kill it that's he her means
luck yeah a is the size of a freaking
Kia but he's got nothing to prove right
so he took his he took his he got to
find out about him
became a professional there you go you
know and so in order to execute the job
he did so without losing his temper
that's right you know without turning
without mislabeling the aggression
that's right
and so but you can make a decision and
say well I you know I grew up in that
neighborhood and so that's how we are
right and I used to have a pastor to say
some families take the family sin mm-hmm
and they give it a name like it's a pet
ah that's just the way the Bologna's do
it right obsessed this is how we are
yeah we just speak our mind translation
you're freaking rude we're ugly we're
mean people yes right you don't take
other people's feelings in syringe right
where it is bad we're passionate no
you're right jolly that's right we eat
our our sadness look well good man
that's exactly right and Twinkies in and
in angel food cake right so you can in
you can pass those sins down
generationally if you were officially if
you make them a pet and they're like a
glorified that's right it's a badge of
honor yeah it's a badge of honor where I
come from that's right and for those of
you who aren't watching Dave right now
he just he puffed his chest up it was a
it was a fascinating read when I learned
in psychology that men especially often
show they often express depression in
that way double chrétien depression is
they puff their chest out really they
get loud because they don't have the
wiring to say I'm hurting they don't
have the skills that nobody's put those
tools in their toolkit when they were
kids to say I have never heard that this
hurts and so they puffed their chest up
and so any time to be careful doing
anytime I says I'm not depressed why I
hug you all the time Dave cuz you just
tell him sad
that's right but bless your heart what
the the possess body positioning you had
was something that we see right we see
guys go rear and women often go step
down Wow
right and they grab control by by
ducking and pulling everybody down with
them to this sad little moment and so
yeah being able to say here's where I
come from here's what I'm gonna take
from that and then here's where we're
gonna go mmm that last caller he's
changing not only family tree but the
destination needs that discussion right
now absolutely does that holster needs
that discussion
instead of four-year-olds throwing
temper fits just everybody yelling
everybody's screaming yeah stop stop
yeah and you know and anybody that I
disagree with has to be labeled a racist
or or evil or if you're if you're a woke
skinny jean wearer then all you know all
sixty-year-old southern white guys must
be they have to be by definition evil
and a minimum they're boomers and by the
way I am a boomer so by the way it was
not a term of derision until about 18
months ago no it used to be a
demographic analysis yeah it's always
been division but oh you're Millennials
what are you a gen Xer
I'm you're an extra yeah you got to be
an extra that's what you are think
anybody who says I don't know what I am
I'm just special yeah there on the
border yeah you know the problem with
snowflakes is there when the heat comes
up they melt spam you're special
that's just puffed your chest out when
you did that I felt like that's all that
I felt this felt I'll crap aside this is
such a good discussion yeah because
everyone that matures everyone that
moves from where you are with money with
your career your marriage your parenting
the things we talked about it Ramsey
solutions your spiritual walk your
physical condition everyone that moves
to get better has to get some
psychological tools and some success
tools some behavior tools that says I'm
not going to blame my past I'm gonna
honor the good parts and move on in the
way you actually do that with your money
the first thing you tell people is to
make a budget and the first thing I do
when I sit down with somebody to say
write them down write down
the bricks that you're carrying right
down the tragedies you're carrying right
down the feelings that are all over your
head and filled your head with smoke and
flame and firecrackers write them down
and that's what I would call a
psychological budget it does the same
thing it does what it does is it takes
the wind out of the sails of those evil
demon that's right because once you put
it on paper they're like a little
squeaky animal and I can scribble that
off and I'm gonna like it's not as bad
as I thought it was when I was in my
head or you can read people write it
down and I go hey that's a big one
you talk to somebody and you know it's
conic I got some student loans how much
230,000 bucks that's a lot right so it's
just taking ownership ownership and if
we've got people in our communities that
aren't taking ownership then we pull up
a chair next to them and we say oh I'll
help you we'll do this together we got
to take ownership of this because
tomorrow's coming whether we want to
drag it whether we don't drag our past
with us or not yep good stuff man it's
good discussion and it's just so
positive for everyone's walk ahead as
lightly as possible